[Music]
it isn't
fair these people they coming
in and uh they get the cream of the cop
crop I don't think it's fair as
all here in New York the migrant crisis
100,000 migrants people seeking Asylum
are CR controversial migrant shelter in
Brooklyn New
York overd in New York City string of
robberies and assault attackers under
arrest time in the city have arrived in
New York
City go
Grandpa
I'm Frank Tamaro and I'm 74 years
old
94 I'm satisfied where I am now I was
satisfied where I was until they drew me
out it was scary I didn't know where I
was
going I'm Barbara NADA I'm the daughter
Frank
Tamaro which was thrown out of Island
Shores due to migrants
Island Shores is an independent living
facility for seniors he moved in he was
living there for 5
years and they evicted
him so I had to find him a place to
live which I did and he hated it there
had winds it up falling and he didn't
want to go back there soone is saying no
of course come back and live with
me so my kids gave up their
room and they come and they visit me
every once in a while they come on the
couch which believe me they do not care
they'll do it for their
grandfather but it's just the point like
are you kidding me you know I can't
leave them a home alone I raised my kids
already they're all grown-ups I mean
he's a piece of cake C you don't you
know but still still 94 years
old they didn't give too much notice and
we knew something was going to go there
homeless something was going to go in
there they said that they had to
restructure the place they never said
they were getting migrants because we
were we asked them it was very
disgraceful what they did to the people
in Island
Shores I said no no no no you're not
moving me and they said yes yes yes we
are and it uh everything was done behind
closed
doors it's no joke getting thrown out of
a house I felt horrible
first of all I have nothing against the
migrants if they would have came in like
my grandparents did like everybody else
did they came in from all Island they
were examined and everything
else then they were allowed to come into
the states and as soon as they came in
they had to have a job here they comeing
in and they get wads of money
I don't get as much as they get it aners
me these migrants they're getting
everything they're getting everything
and I can't get nothing for
him I blame the politicians somebody's
filling their
pockets there's got to be something
going underneath the table they don't
just take immigrants in like that and
place them in the and get rid of a
people in in a in a place where they
were living just like that I say the May
did a horrible job on it he should have
never accepted them the amount of people
coming in he knew we couldn't handle
that where were you going to put all
these
people
I felt bitter at the beginning but now
being with my daughter and everything
else it sort of when on the back burners
but I do get upset when I see them
handing out all this money and all these
things and I'm paying
taxes I I don't understand it at all
it's not fair to to anybody they're
going to be living the good
life before American
though